[Music]
miley cyrus trades in her wrecking ball
for a disco ball at the vmas
the 27 year old's performance of
midnight sky
seemed pretty straightforward at first
she took to the stage
solo giving us 80s vibes rocking out
with just her mic
but towards the end of her performance
miley ripped off her skirt
and climbed on top of a giant disco ball
making a reference to her iconic
wrecking ball video which won video of
the year at the 2014
vmas i think it's for people they feel
like this is the place that they can be
the most expressive
and so i think that there's not a lot of
boundaries and so
the line that is very thin line you can
go over it
yeah it gets drawn farther and farther
away
it makes sense that the singer would
give a nod to her 2013 hit
just last week she celebrated wrecking
balls 7th anniversary
on instagram writing quote 7 years of
wrecking ball
my concept of time is completely askew
feels like
a lifetime ago but somehow only
yesterday
thank you for all the support you gave
me then and of course the love you're
continuing to show my art today
forever grateful and inspired
[Music]
before her performance of midnight sky
miley
stunned in a revealing sparkly sheer
number
on the red carpet accessorizing her look
with a silver choker
chunky earrings and bright red lipstick
the singer's history at the vmas
includes that memorable
2013 performance taking the stage as
host in 2015 and last year
she debuted her emotional single slide
away
but all eyes were on miley as she took
the stage
this year and she did not disappoint